zakat are you go can you go all hear us
can you all see us yes yes well they're
excited to be here as we all know i'm
here with Cliff Curtis who plays um
Travis Manawa and of course Dave
Erickson
co-creator writer and executive producer
others one of our favorite show Oh Dave
how are you I
13 3 4 5 6 there's eight of you guys you
guys im just gonna change really quickly
so we are introduced each other to we
all know who each other are and if you
could just raise your hand or just say
hi make sure that everyone's here so we
have Miriam from the Netherlands now
open the neighborhood Miriam Mirren's
not here okay I'm sure she'll come
briefly into the conversation and or
from Hungary oh let's see hi guys are
you uh
um daniel from czech republic that's me
hello hey I got no where are you in
crock yeah I'm frack nice also from
Thailand a manic sowwy
hi is that how you pronounce your name
my not gonna leave leg up
Geralt I'm Singapore
thank you oh yeah I cut them on my
camera
okay oh yeah you're here yeah damn yeah
but you can see us now right yes again
buffet be no Jason from the UK hi guys
how are you more again also from the UK
[Music]
lady Morgan mark mark is not here yet
either Jarrett from South Africa hi
there nut stuff you guys can see me yeah
yeah again
and I ease will still
high
alright perfect so we're all here we're
very very excited as I just mentioned
why don't we start with a NAND or Nandor
you have a question along what to expect
for this season
yes um I really like the first season I
could feel that there were some shark
fist in it and then I'm really enjoyed
but should we should be counseled
something more relaxing call more linear
so telling or
are there gonna be like such a big twist
that in the purchase of the goods we're
gonna get some Sun lotion
and some are Ella's and some sunglasses
and we chill out Oh on the ocean no
we're not itzhak it's it's not it will
not be a relaxed quick will not be
relaxin for anyone we will be on the
Abigail so we'll be at sea but will
quickly discover that C is no safer than
land so it's it there will be more
twists and turns and it's gonna be it's
gonna be tensed a lot more action
fantasy I felt like my step is yeah yes
feels like even impossible up for action
there's there's over now I mean we're
now much we're into the apocalypse now I
mean season one mm-hmm we you know my
family to a certain degree was was
insulated by the moment they realized
what was happening the National Guard
had showed up ended up spending more so
it's behind a fee on defense trusting
what information they were being given
and now everything's been falling away
though I think you know the deeper we
get into the apocalypse no more
dangerous will become and you know we're
not quite at the point where Rick Grimes
wakes up no the walking dead in the
original show but we're getting we're
getting much closer to getting close
daniel from czech republic you also I
wanted to know a little bit more about
how it went all right yeah that's my
question definitely because it's really
interesting for me so
what was it so it's my question but we
went we knew we were gonna be shooting
on a boat and we our production designer
Bernardo Trujillo who is from Mexico
City is he designed and built the
Abigail in about six weeks and you know
and we went to run another five studios
in Rosarito because they that's where
James Cameron built his studio to film
the Titanic film Titanic and they have a
massive horizon tank which is where our
boat now lives and they have three other
water tanks stages so the action for the
for the elements we wanted for season
two we they just seemed at the right
place to go
thank you spice um you also mentioned
wanted to know the challenges
we can't hear like well
maybe it's your mind you wanna do you
want to try and fix your microphone real
quick just in the meantime then let me
go to my new sowwy you also had a lot of
questions about season two
[Music]
well she wants to know we can't hear you
very well but um I know exactly what you
mean she wants to know that if there are
any characters that leave the show or
get written off in the next season and
if snow and if you can give her any
heads will it be a matter
that's an excellent question and you
know that's my bisco I'm constantly
asking you know I'm always asked it was
like you know die no one just tell me
man
other way tell me if I'm gonna get bit
please
typically tell us honey I'm not our and
anyone can be been at any time and it's
in and and as you know from you know
from the original shown from Robert
Kirkman's comic it's it's not just such
a snot just the walkers they act a bit
dangerous it's other people that will
meet but um I
can't tell me I'm sorry okay but you
know what probably it's right choice
you're fantastic question you can figure
out who it's gonna be please
okay let's go over to Gerard um girag we
can see now i'm pretty sure are you
there i'm gonna hit me can't that we can
hear you more importantly you also had
questions about different elements on
both
yeah my question is because season one
was a bit shot in it in the sense of
terms of episodes just wondering were
there any elements that you had to
remove in season one that we will be
able to see in season two
um
no not really I mean I feel like we told
it was really one chapter season so we
told
his introduction into the apocalypse and
now and they learned you know they learn
what the infected were I mean I think
Travis a special infected work and it
really is an extension of that's what
other word so we in the way we break
down this season we actually do it in
two parts so the room runs about 17
episodes and then the back half is 8 so
it's really for me it's really treat
there's three chapters in a novel
but so no there was a birth there was
really anything they'd be good to be
doomed is it one that we are die side
from the boat but didn't find the book
okay a lot of you guys also were very
curious are very curious to you a little
bit more about what happens to Travis in
seconds in and I'm sure there's a lot of
things you won't be able to answer but
um
Jared I jurors I know that um in your
first question
your first question is basically about
Travis and his his role in this sect
second season correct you know what are
you know what
you would like to sleep at booth
right oh
well you know I want them too hard
enough I want traffic
you know it's like I really like Travis
I think it's written by I really like to
do and I think it is my friend
they're great teacher in your high
school would be good to the kids and
stuff but then assam be apocalypse I was
like he's just not cutting it this is
this kind of like really or you know
it's like or where is just because you
know the issue I have is that you know
there are so many other
really capable characters that are much
better adapted to be my college like
strand and Salazar arm and you know the
characters of Madison the neck a much
quicker to a debt to the fact that you
gotta kill to survive then Travis I
think that you know i
wanna i want to keep my job which means
that i was five I want to survive the
apocalypse athletes that I want to I
want my character to evolve where he has
a worldview they make sure that he's
gonna he's gonna make it
cuz Travis is like gold making behind I
think the risk of
characters
here's thing I think what's interesting
to me about and one and I've image
[Music]
that I is there someone doing it
no I
ache Travis in season one was very much
the moral compass of the show and I
think by the end of the season he
realizes you know any good action you
know that even he did he attends any
effort to hold on to his morality is
actually becoming a compromise in this
world you know and I think that's what
extends into his season two and a much
more comfortable with
and only affected pretty pretty I can
say that
Jason yep man you also had um questions
about
what no
that's right yeah I think the question I
was asking was i see for fear the
walking dead the universe where zombies
never really existed in popular culture
I was basically asking obviously how do
you think our modern-day will would be
faced with a similar threat with the
knowledge gained from shows like fear
the walking dead
I think I think I think
I think we'd been a habit thanks to the
show
and it ever did come into being it be
millions and people though in the world
who'd know it would have thought about
this for the last five years so I know
exactly what they could
I'm sure number of you guys have got
clear ideas about you do I cuz I think
we I think I think it's a the world is a
better place for this franchise
but for the possibility of a zombie
apocalypse
for paranoid Oh
paranoid yeah
you know I would I do i do look in the
know I figure out where we're confide I
do i do look at the glasses because I
wonder that's not a BC witness lee
fisher that's okay so yeah it's think
that my
faith healings you're sort of iterator
no more oh yeah I wouldn't want to be
stuck in LA in a zombie apocalypse I
supposedly feel a lot safer with back to
New Zealand
I've got a pretty good idea how I'd
organize my community get involved in my
community helps all cash things I know
them I know the friends that I want to
have around me you got some pretty good
friends in very handy yeah would be up
there we would be able to grow around
food I know I know exactly Gilda
thank God Nelly I don't know okay I'm
gonna get
I've definitely become a little more
paranoid since i watch I'm always
looking how I'm going to escape all
right so let's move on to Morgan from
the UK
have a few questions
yeah I was just wondering um hmm look at
this I was wondering what you could tell
us about some of the new characters who
are joining in in season two it's a
really good question
sadly
[Laughter]
I give it I would say this we are going
to meet folks on landed on see um
it's just it's tricky because it would
give it I think would give too many
tells to the story that's going to
develop over the next the next several
weeks um you know but it's it's put it
this way we're not the only we're not
the only people who had the bright idea
to take to the water you know and I
think very quickly we're going to
realize that there's there's going to be
competition on on the ocean yeah I'm
gonna say something to it and
they're not a lot of friends ok
yeah ok yeah
i can i can say that much oh well
there's potential friends but you know
but not really there's not a lot we
found out there in this situation ah
well oh no I
want to go back to lie eighties and we
couldn't hear you before it and I don't
want to leave you out of the
conversation do you want to type your
question cuz we could definitely read if
you type something in
perfect just type something I'm going to
move on to someone else and then come
right back to you um ok so let's go back
to NAND or um what else would you like
to have it
well there was this very interesting
question or phrase Daniel Salazar said
that the good people are the ones who
died in the first time so I'm I'm
franchises do you think that you would
be wants to die in the first time where
you yes fab yours
yeah and I think I that's why I totally
believe that Travis is the least likely
to survive apocalypse because he's like
good guy and it's like constrain our
characters like strand and Stella's are
like most likely survive and characters
like Madison and Nick are the most
likely to adapt quickly be able to
survive canvases way down on the ladder
of you know being a goodie guy doesn't
do a lot of favors in this builder I
really that's like it's a bit of a
problem
bunty develops I mean getting more and
more
Travis is your fault it's all in the
Abbess gravis learned a great deal is
one about how to survive in this world
but he's another copy me who ended we on
season one with a guy who was forced to
put a bullet into the mother of his son
so that's not something I'm going to go
away very very soon and fundamentally
the show started and it is
it is a family drama it's a
dysfunctional blended family drama and
it's just a far more complicated going
into season bonus season two so no one
has to worry about trap Travis's ability
to deal with the dead is not get it will
be addressed and you'll see that very
clearly but there's a whole level of new
complications and complexity to his
relationship with his son and with
Madison and with the rest of the people
trapped on boat I think it's a good it's
a relevant question in that one of the
sister of themes of the second season is
about you know
I'm what do you have to become a
survivor you know what Ian to get up
about your morality your values you a
sense of identity about being a good guy
what are you willing to do to survive
and travis has not really a survivalist
he's more of an idealist and his focus
maintain is
[Music]
core beliefs in the second season that
was what most of what is most important
town business family not his survival
which is really distinct so really just
is it there's a real distinction there
he and his family is not just blood his
family thatís a peck and and Alicia and
his own son he's not he's just not a
survivalist energy that's what's so
attractive about characters like strand
and Salazar in this world is because
they they are pure survivalists I mean
sure Salazar as his family but he's not
going to take too much time to grieve
missing most what what the priority is a
strand again this like he's a very
attractive character as well maybe not
in real life we don't want a strand in
our life but in a zombie apocalypse he's
very he's very helpful he's got a very
fear of how the world what the world is
and how to UM break that well and Travis
is just not in that place and he's got
he's got a he's got to go through a big
transition to BL
offer his family whether it be Madison
or neck or a leash or his own son
anything that's helpful or useful to
them if he's got a you know
be a man that's able to protect and
provide for his family
fundamentally that and that's what
actually attract
doesn't mean a thing is if this what we
didn't want to do in season one and I
think we want to avoid it in season two
you the tree he was and we talked about
this a lot of last season there any any
zombie film is the real everyone is up
speed everybody knows I'm kill everybody
realizes how to kill and
we wanted to do i think was tell a story
where there wasn't a shorthand where
people actually had to actually rasp and
wrestle with the reality and with facing
which was a bit of the reason why things
on round I think spelled out a little
bit slower in the first season fun
there's an acceleration going into the
still be alive there are some very good
question which I don't think we can sort
of give away what this question they'll
be questioned I don't want to I don't
even know what the answers are but this
is some big very big questions that are
going to be raised and the chicken
caesar
around combos that it's going to take
the folks in for second season
we're only halfway to shooting so we got
closer
sorry
ok now we're going to back to ladies and
I'm gonna say I'm gonna tell them hey oh
no
so and I want to ask you another
question to continue that kind of that
line of thoughts and I say it yes yes ah
to cliff and let season ended with the
shocking outcome of the death of Lisa
right so why do you think that Travis
will add how do you think the tribes we
react to this page and on the fact that
he also has to do with his own feelings
for the bottom his ex-wife in this
figure out how to act in front of his
cell and the group yeah i think that you
know i think Travis in the normal world
would probably don't get drunk and and
cry for a month and you know you know
they'll very very bad about what he's
done but this isn't a zombie apocalypse
and there's no time for Greek and we we
pick up and the second seasonings right
on and that's one of the interesting
things about Travis's that then the
season one we set up the possibility
that if he asked that you didn't kill a
single zombie or infected didn't kill me
here they infected through the entire
season even with everything they did I
had a shotgun he had a shotgun again and
the first hill was that the mother of
his child was a woman that he loved
now
he's why what basically is going to
happen is that it's going to be
internalized he's not gonna grieve he's
not going to have a real real chance to
behave in a normal way and that's going
to affect him and I still don't know
what come to us this is one of the
question what's gonna happen Travis
onion
well the first thing is that he
understand that he has to kill
but what happened so fast and it's so
intense the second season but he just
doesn't get a chance to understand what
that mean that you have to go perhaps on
a daily basis I also want to go back to
nandura because I thought he has a very
interesting question in regards to the
government there the role play to me
Percy go Redmond yeah thank you very
much for letting me asking this question
so well as I see you're not
so
good with the government or as I say um
the government was very bad in crisis
management how do you rank it wouldn't
want to pass scale I'm good at improve
in the next season um i would say given
the chance just a problem at about us
six a scale of 1-10 but I know oh then
off series when I touch to Erickson
Holly theory about the whole thing it's
interesting it's interesting because I
do think the short answer is at the
National Guard comes across being a
little bit villainous but I think that
in some of the guardsmen that we met it
was a bit of a bit more community I
think we have a better understanding you
know we've got three you know at the end
of the season the guardsmen trended
heading off to San Diego because they
too can't the process what's going on
other is their families and in in the
world of the walking dead in the way way
Robert Kirkman established
the show we never tell it through the
perspective of try not the military or
government institutions so we had a an
indication of what was going on with the
guard and how they were trying to
contain the outbreak last season we
more or less put that aside going this
it'll really be more just about our
family and
trying to survive now that's
institutions of all
no one's trying to look like a damn
anymore key
let's go back to Daniel now and you
wanted to ask clip questions about this
particular genre and
the different roles that he's played in
in this John rock and what's his
favorite
yeah I wouldn't like to ask what kind of
movie is your favorite about you know
with a zombie team so I'm a huge fan of
Romero movies so what kind of movie is
your favorite about no George Romero
[Music]
well I really like Danny Boyle's
alex carlin dr cook 20 23 28 29 28 days
later
yeah that's great I thought that was
a
really great
setup and I thought that how he how he
how he
just felt very
visceral and and he and he and he gave
us a plausible reason
to why the outbreak happened I said he
just took that question of the table not
on the street would have made from some
kind of
[Music]
a medical experiment that went wrong an
outbreak occurred and it just seems very
plausible
so I really I really liked it and also i
like i like how i like the scale of it
as well because it was just basically
focusing on a an individual who's
they're just running he's geared and
and
doesn't know what's going on so i just
really like that okay thank you i also
analyst illus i was saying he was so
caught up for the military stuff as well
yep which would he did what you did with
the sea corsets yeah I really never
that's my favorite
I also wanted to bring up flight 462 a
few of you guys have asked questions
about it and um Morgan go ahead
well I just wanted to ask about about
that that's showin and how what we saw
there is going to play into the second
season of fear the walking dead it will
play into the second season I can't say
exactly when and how but we will
probably see some characters we met on
that plane both will local reemerge at
some point are you sure
May could happen in May May so hard it's
so hard to answer these questions
because it's
yeah man so it's a all the plot points
in the turns over coming but um no but
it's definitely i love i love the you're
on the right track I like personally I
like the idea of conflating narratives
and i think it's it's you know
especially these days where you can do
multi-platform storytelling whether it's
the show a movie a game webisodes I mean
that's actually kind of fun and we're
we're talking now about doing another
interstitial another webisode series
between seasons two and three of fear so
you know so there's there are some
characters that we seem to have left
behind and sees one who may they may
have new life yeah like a lady who and
inside think you should do in the life
after fear yeah
but what I really like about it is that
you've got now you've got land sea and
air that's what I think scoop here that
that the that you've got these you know
your capital I'd wondering I suppose you
gotta go into space sneaks
into the universe into the zombie you if
you didn't get that movie I did I did
that movie is well worth Danny Boyle
also have a question in regards to fight
for 62 actually a couple
can you hear me like ya hey um so
today's and as a show Ron there what
were the greatest challenge when it
comes to take risk is he making a new
kind of way to tell that story to live
into juice and you character in a broad
that was a really establishing what was
there in kind of discussion when you
were creating the characters in this
story or about the closure of the events
whose okay I'm gonna just repeat urs
genuine yes um
the risk what were the greatest
challenges when it comes to taking risks
making a new kind of way to tell a story
which is um like 462 I mean it's we
wanted to do something I mean well first
of all we had to be relatively well
contained because the story itself is is
so short it's only about 60 minutes and
all of its component parts and then
there may be the biggest challenge is
figure out a way to integrate
potentially integrate that story with
the larger world of fear the walking
dead you know and I think it was
as soon as we figured out a way to link
it to the larger narrative I think that
was that that was the biggest challenge
and once we had that then everything
kind of fell into place
yeah thank you girag you had a very
interesting question also and a few of
you want to know a little bit more about
this and it's in regards to whether
there will be a crossover
fear the walking dead and you walk into
itself shanty [ __ ] universe concept mum
so when it's a show going to actually
acknowledge it and have a proper
crossover would it be anytime soon or
you see it in the eye
I
unless the short answer is no
it's largely because I mean just in
terms of the geography it's very
difficult to link the two stories just
they'd have to trek across
the continental divide and head to the
east coast I also think that as its
innovative as The Walking Dead is they
are you know they are adhering to the
comic so it gets hit again my things
complicated for us to pull off because
we'd have to then it would break from
the it would break from the narrative it
think of the comic book which would
which unsure is not something that
Robert would be interested in doing and
the other in the other challenge is
chronologically they are about the six
going on seven see deep into their story
and where we're still catching up with
them so i think the timelines probably
will never quite quite Mary
unfortunately I think it's that I think
it other thing is that
when I've been looking at the seasons
too I can totally see that we are on
going out season one
yeah
interest for now show was really the
other show but I think season to our
characters and the stories that are
being developed we've got our own China
stay on this you know the show anymore
everything we can step feet because I
think it's really good enough
and you know I'm very fussy right i'm
saying i would say that like I didn't
think it was gonna be any good at I tell
you however it's yeah it's looking
really good
but what if maybe hypothetically
speaking if you guys actually didn't
mean how do you think things actually
play out
if it if the two families of the two the
two shows met and all those
well you know I think Travis is a very
very jealous man and I think worried
that Rick Grimes would be very
attractive to medicine
all right gonna have to interrupt
because our time is up and I think I
could speak for all of us we could
probably stay and talk about this all
day long this has been amazing right it
was for thank you for doing the game
only tell you this my girlfriend mate
it's a hanging said so she makes these
bears bloody and masters but the key is
this button yeah when you have children
you'll be able to get
you guys we really mean it was amazing
hanging out with you guys I'll be able
to do it I just want want everybody to
know those of you that don't season 2
will premiere April tets in all Latin
America and April Evans in Asia and
Europe and it'll be just minutes after
the broadcast here in the US which is at
nine um nine eight bedrooms so don't
miss it thank you so so much to you
thank you
bye hi guys
[Music]